དེ་ག་རེ་རེད།
སྔོན་མ་སྔོན་མ་(ར)། བྱིའུ་གཅིག་སྔོན་ནས་ཡོད་(བ)། མར་ཕུར་སོང་ད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་དཔེ་དགའ་བོ་ར་
བྱིའུ་དེ་ཡོད་(བ་)ཤིང་སྡོང་སྒང་ལ་འགྲོ་སོང་ད་
ཡོད་(བ་)
དེ་ནས་མར་བབས་སོང་ཐང་ལ་
བྱིའུ་གཅིག་ཡོད་(བ་)ཡོད་(བ་)མར་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་ཡི་འདུག་ད་༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་ཡོད་བ
བྱིའུ་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེ་སོང་བུ་མོ་
༼ཨ་ནས་༽མར་ཕུར་སོང་ད་༼ཨ་ནས་༽མར་ཁེར་སོང་གནམ་ལ། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁོ་དཔེ་དགའ་བོ་དགའ་སོང་
ཡང་ཁོ་༼གིས་༽ Jeli ཟ་ཡི་འདུག Jeli
ཁ་སང་སྔོན་མ་སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)། སྔོན་སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཡོད་(བ)། བྱིའུ་༼ཨ་ནས་༽མར་བབས་དུས་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཡོད་(བ)། ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེས་སོང་ད།
དེ་སྟོན་ད། སྔོན་མ་སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ང་འགྲོ་དུས་འགྲོ་དུས་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཡོད་(བ)། བྱིའུ་གཅིག་ཐུག་སོང་། བྱིའུ་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་མ་མཐོང་སོང་།
ཁོ་༼གིས་༽རྩེད་མོ་རྩེས་སོང་།
ཡོད་(བ)། མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེས་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས༽། ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽དཔེ་དགའ་སོང་། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽མཉམ་དུ་ཁ་ལག་ཟ་སོང་།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽མར་ཉལ་སོང་། དགོང་དག་དགོང་དག་ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་ཉལ་སོང་། བྱིའུ་མཉམ་དུ།
བྱིའུ་ཡོད་(བ་)ཤིང་སྡོང་སྒང་ལ་མར་
ལྗང་ཁུ། སེར་པོ། དམར་པོ་འོ་དེ་ཚོ་ཚང་མ་འགྲོ་ད།
འོ་དེ་གིས། ནང་ལ་ང་ཚོའི་ནང་ལ།
ད་ཁྱེད་རང་ལབ་དང་།
ལྗངས་ཁུང་གོན་འདུག ལྗངས་ཁུ་
གོས་ཐུང་རེད།
གོན་འདུག
ཨི་ནས་མར། ཨི་ནས་མར་རྐང་པོ་བརྒྱུས་ནས།
ད་ཁྱོད་ལབ་ད།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཁྱོད་ལབ་ད། ཁྱོད་ཚང་མ་ལབ་ད།
སྔོན་མ་སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ)། འགྲོ་༼དུས་བསམ་པ་༽ཡོད་(བ)།
བྱིའུ་གཅིག་མར་ཨི་ནས་མར་བབས་སོང་ད། ཨི་ནས་མར། འོ་དེ་ནང་ལ་འགྲོ་སོང་།
སྔོན་མ་སྔོན་མ་བྱིའུ་གཅིག་བབས་སོང་ད། ཡོད་(བ)། བྱིའུ་ཁོ་མཉམ་དུ་རྩེད་མོ་རྩེས་སོང་ད་ཡོད་(བ)།
ཡོད་(བ)། བུ་མོ་དེ་དཔེ་དགའ་བོ་དགའ་སོང་ད།
ཡོད་(བ)། ༼ཨ་ནས་༽ཡོད་(བ)། སྔོན་མ་ཡོད་(བ་)ཁ་སང་ཡོད་(བ)།
བྱིའུ་ཡོད་(བ)།
བབས་སོང་ད་བྱིའུ་ཁོ།
བུ་མོ་སྙིང་རྗེ་མོ་གཅིག་ཡོད་རེད་(ད)།འོ་དེ་ངུ་ཡི་འདུག་(ད)། སོ་བཀྲུ།
གདོང་པ་བཀྲུ། གོས་སློག་གོན་བྱེ་དཀྱི་འདུག ཁ་ལག་དེ་ཚོ་བཟས་ནས།
གཟའ་སྤེན་པོ་སློབ་གྲྭ་ལ་འགྲོ་ཡི་འདུག ཁོང་ཚོ།
༼ཨ་ནས་༽ལྗངས་ཁུ་སེར་པོ་དམར་པོ་ཚང་མ།
ང་ལ་(chewin gum)དགོས།